The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
So today we're
going to do some
really cool stuff
having to do with
nondeterministic parallel
programming.
This is where the course
starts to get hard.
Because nondeterminism
is really nasty.
We'll talk about
it a little bit.
It's really nasty.
Parallel computing, as you
know, is pretty easy, right?
It's just work and span.
Easy stuff, right?
It makes sense.
You can measure these
things, can learn some skills
around them, and so forth.
But nondeterminism is
nasty, really nasty.
So first let's talk about
what we mean by determinism.
So we say that a program is
deterministic on a given input
if every memory location is
updated with a sequence--
the same sequence of
values in every execution.
So the program always
behaves the same.
And you may end up-- if it's
a parallel program having
different memory locations
updated in different orders--
I may do A and then B, versus
updating B and then A--
but if I look at a single
memory location, A say,
I'm always updating A with
the same sequence of values.
There are lots of
definitions of determinism.
This is not the only one.
There are some where
people say, well, it only
matters if the output
is always the same.
And there are others where
you say not only does it
have to be the same but
every write to a location
has to be in the
same order globally.
That turns out to be
actually pretty hard,
because if you have
parallel computing
you're not going to get them
all updated the same unless you
only have one processor
executing instructions.
And so we'll talk about this.
We'll talk a little bit more
about this kind of thing.
So why-- what's
the big advantage
of deterministic programs?
Why should we care whether
it's deterministic or
nondeterministic?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: It's repeatable.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
It's repeatable.
OK.
So what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a lot
of programs [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON: Why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] like a--
Why?
Because sometimes
that's what you want.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Because
sometimes that's what you want.
OK.
That doesn't-- so if--
I mean, there's a lot of
things I might sometimes want.
Why is that important
to want that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because
consistency makes
it easier to debug source code.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
Makes it easier to debug.
That's probably the number
one reason, debugging.
If it does the same thing every
time, then if you have a bug,
you can run it again.
You expect to see the bug again.
So every time you run through,
hey, I get the same bug.
But if it's nondeterministic,
I get a bug,
and now I go to look for it and
the bug is nowhere to be found.
Makes debugging a lot harder.
There are other reasons
for wanting repeatability,
so your answer is actually
a broader correct answer.
But the big advantage is
in the specific application
of repeatability to debugging.
So here's the golden rule
of parallel programming.
Never write nondeterministic
parallel programs.
They can exhibit
anomalous behaviors
and it's hard to debug them.
So never ever write
nondeterministic programs.
Unfortunately, this is one
of these things that is
kind of hard in practice to do.
So why might you want to write
a nondeterministic program
even though--
even when famous masters
in the area of performance
engineering, with
highly credentialed--
numerous awards and
so forth, tell you
you shouldn't write
nondeterministic programs?
Why might you want
to do it anyway?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You get
better performance.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
You might get
better performance.
That's one of the big ones.
And sometimes you can't.
The nature of the
problem is maybe
that it's not deterministic.
You may have asynchronous
inputs coming in and so forth.
So this is the golden rule.
We also have a silver rule.
Silver rule says never write
nondeterministic parallel
programs, but if you must
always devise a test strategy
to manage the nondeterminism.
So this gets into
you better have
some way of handling how
you're going to tell what's
going on if you have a bug.
So what are some of the
typical test strategies
that you could use that would
manage the nondeterminism?
So imagine you've got
a parallel program
and it's got races
in it and so forth,
and it's operating
nondeterministically.
What-- and that's OK if
everything's going right.
How would you-- you find
a bug in the program.
How are you-- what
are you going to do?
What kinds of ideas do you have?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You could temporarily
remove the nondeterminism.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
You could turn off
the nondeterminism.
You put a switch in
there that says, well,
I know the source of this
nondeterministic behavior.
Let me do that.
Let me give you an
example of that.
For security reasons these
days, when you allocate memory,
it's allocated to
different locations
on different runs
of the program.
It's allocated in random places.
They want to randomize the
addresses when you call malloc.
That means that you can end
up with different behaviors
from run to run, and that can
compromise your performance.
But it turns out that
there is a compiler switch,
and if you run it
in debug mode it
will always deliver
the results of malloc
in deterministic
locations, where
the locations of the
things you're mallocing
are repeatable.
So that's good because
they're supported.
They said, yes, we have to
randomize for security reasons
so that people can't
deterministically
exploit buffer overflow
errors, for example,
but I don't want to have
to do that every time.
So I don't want to
randomize every time I run.
I want to have the
option of making it
so that that randomization
is turned off.
So that's a good one.
What's another one
that can be done?
You're full of good ideas.
Let's try somebody else for now.
But I like that, I like that.
What are some other ideas?
What else can you do to
handle nondeterminism?
You got a program and it's--
yes, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: If you use random
numbers, use the same seed.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
If you have random numbers,
you use the same seed.
In some sense that's
kind of the same thing
if you're turning
off nondeterminism.
But that's a great one.
There are other places.
For example, if you read--
if you do get time of day
for something in your program
for something, you could have
an option where it will put
in a particular fixed value
there so you can make sure that
it doesn't--
even a serial program
isn't nondeterministic.
So that's good, but I also
consider that to be-- it's
another great example of
turning off and on determinism.
What other things can you do?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You could record the
randomized outputs or inputs
to determine correctness.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
You can do record-replay
for some things.
Is that what you're saying?
Is that what you mean?
Or am I--
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: So
record-replay says you run it
through-- you can run it
through with random numbers,
but it's recording those things,
so that when you run it again,
instead of using
the random numbers--
new random numbers, it uses
the ones that you used to use.
So that's the
record-replay thing.
Is that what you're saying, or
are you saying something else?
Yes, OK, good.
So that's using some tools.
There are actually
a lot of strategies.
Let me just move on and answer.
So another thing you can do is
encapsulate the nondeterminism.
So that's actually done in a
Cilk runtime system already.
The runtime system is using
a random scheduling strategy,
but you don't see that it's
random in the execution
of your code if you don't--
if you have no race conditions
in your code.
It's encapsulated.
So that the-- in the platform.
So the platform is
going to guarantee
you deterministic results even
though underneath the covers
it's doing
nondeterministic things.
You can also substitute a
deterministic alternative.
Sometimes there's a way
of computing something
that is nondeterministic,
but in debug mode,
ah, let me not use the
nondeterministic one.
And you can also
use analysis tools,
which can tell you
things about your program
and which you can
control things.
So there's a lot of things.
So whenever you have a
nondeterministic program,
you want to find some
way of controlling it.
Often, the nondeterminism
is over in this corner
but your bug is
over in this corner.
So if you can turn this
thing off in some way,
or encapsulate it,
or otherwise control
the nondeterminism
over there, now you
have a better chance of
catching the stuff over here.
That's going to be particularly
important in project 4
when we get to
it, because that's
going to be actually
going to be doing
nondeterministic programming
for a game playing program.
And one of the things
is that the processors
are, in this case, keeping
the game positions together.
And so if one processor
stores something
into what's called a
transposition table, which
is essentially a big hash
table of positions it's seen,
another one can see that
value and change its behavior.
And so one of the
things you want to be do
is turn off transposition
table so that you
don't take advantage of
that performance advantage,
but now you can debug
the search code,
or you can debug the
evaluation code, and so forth.
You can also do things
like unit testing
so you know whether or not a
particular piece is correct
that might have--
so that you can test
this thing separately
from the rest of your system
which may have nondeterminism.
Anyway, this is a major thing.
So never write them.
But if you have
to, you always want
to have some test strategy.
And so for people who are
not watching this video
and who are not in
class today, they
are going to be
sorely hampered by not
knowing this lesson when they
go into the fourth project.
So what we're going
to do is now we're
going to talk about how to do
nondeterministic programming.
So this is-- there's always
some part of your code
which has a skull
and crossbones.
Like you have this abstraction.
It's beautiful, and you
can design, et cetera.
And then somewhere there's
this really ugly thing
that nobody should know, and
you put the skull and crossbones
on that, and only experts go in.
Well, anyway, that's the
barrier we're crossing here.
And we're going to start out
by talking about something
that you've probably
seen in some
of the other classes, mutual
exclusion and atomicity.
So I'm going to use the
example of a hash table.
So here's a typical hash table.
It's got collisions
resolved by chaining.
So you have a bunch
of linked lists.
You hash to a particular
slot in the table,
and then you chase down the
linked list to find the value.
And so, for example,
if I'm going
to insert x which has
a key value of 81,
what I do is figure
out which slot
I go to by hashing the key.
And then in this case I
made it be the last one
so that the animations
could be easier
than if it were in the middle.
So now what do I do is
I make the pointer of x
go to the first
element of that list,
and then I make the slot
value now point to x.
And that effectively, with a
constant number of operations,
inserts x into the hash
table, and in particular
into the linked list in the
slot that it's supposed to be.
This is all familiar, right?
So now what happens
when you have
multiple parallel
instructions that are
accessing the same locations?
So here we have two
threads, one inserting
x and one inserting y.
And x goes, it does its thing.
It hashes to there, and it
then sets the next pointer
to be the--
to add itself into the list.
And then there's
this other thing
going on in parallel which
effectively says, oh, I'm
going to hash.
Oh, we're going
to the same slot.
It doesn't know that
somebody is already there.
And so then it
decides it's going
to put itself in as the
first element of the list.
And then it sets
the value of y--
it sets the value of
the slot to point to y.
And then along comes x,
finishing off what it's doing,
and it points the value to x.
And you can see that we have a
race bug here, a really nasty
one because we've just destroyed
the integrity of our system.
We now have-- in particular,
y is sort of floating,
not in the list when it's
supposed to be in the list.
So the standard
solution to this is
to make some of these
instructions be atomic.
And what that means is
the rest of the system
can never view them as
being partially executed.
So they either all have been
executed or none of them
have been executed
at any point in time
as far as the rest of
the system is concerned.
And the part of code that
is within the atomic region
is called the critical section.
And, typically, a
critical section of code
is some place that should
not be being executed
by two things at the same time.
So the standard
solution to atomicity
is to use what's called a mutex
lock, or a mutual exclusion
lock.
And it's basically an object
with a lock and unlock member
functions.
And an attempt by a thread to
lock an already locked mutex
causes the thread to block--
that is, wait-- until
the mutex is unlocked.
So if somebody grabs the lock,
somebody else grabs the lock
and it's already taken,
then they have to wait.
And they sit there waiting
until this guy says,
yes, I'm going to release it.
So what we'll do
now is we'll make
each slot be a struct with a
mutex L, and a pointer, head,
to the slot context.
So it's going to
be the same data
structure we had
before but now I'm
going to have not just
the pointer from the slot
but I'll also have a--
also have a lock
in that position.
And so the idea of--
in the code now is that
before I access the lock--
before I access
the list, I'm going
to lock that list in the
table by locking slot.
Then I'll do the things
that I need to do,
and then I'll unlock it, and
now anything else can go on.
Because what's happening
is-- the reason
we're getting into
trouble is because we've
got some sort of
interleaving of operations.
And our goal is to
make sure that it's
either doing this or
doing this, and never
this, to make sure that--
so that each thing,
each piece of code,
is restoring the invariant of
correctness after it executes
the pointer swaps.
The invariance in this
case is that the elements
are in a list.
And so you want to restore
that with each one.
So mutexes-- this is
one way you can use
mutexes to implement atomicity.
So now let's just go back.
Who has seen mutexes before?
Is that pretty much everybody?
Yes.
OK, good.
I hope that this is not brand
new for too many of you.
If it is brand
new, that's great.
But what I'm trying
to do is make it-- so
let's go back a little bit
and recall in this class
our discussion of
determinacy races.
So, remember, a
determinacy race occurs
when you have two logically
parallel instructions
that access the same memory
location and at least one
of them performs a write.
So mutex locks can guarantee
that critical sections behave
atomically, but the
resulting code is
inherently nondeterministic
because you've got a--
we had a race bug there.
We had two things trying
to access the same slot.
But that may be what I want.
I want to have a shared hash
table maybe for these things.
So I want something
where there is a race,
but I just don't want to have
the anomalies that arise.
In this case, the race
bug caused things,
and I can solve
that with atomicity.
If you have no
determinacy races,
it means that the program is
deterministic on that input
and that it always
behaves the same.
And remember also that if
a deterministic race exists
in an ostensibly
deterministic program, then
it guarantees to find a race.
Now, if you put in
mutexes, you still
have a nondeterministic program.
You still have a race.
Because you have two
things that are logically
parallel that are both
accessing the lock.
That's a race.
That's a determinacy race.
If you have two things,
they're in parallel,
they're both accessing the
lock, that's a determinacy race.
It may be a safe, correct one,
but it is a determinacy race.
And so any codes
that use locks are
nondeterministic by
intention, and they're
going to invalidate the Cilksan
guarantee of finding those race
bugs.
So you will end up
with races in your code
if you're not careful.
And so this is one reason
it's important to have
some way of turning off
nondeterminism to detect stuff.
Because what you don't
want is a whole rash
of false positives
saying, oh, you
raced on gathering this lock.
Nor do you want to ignore
that and then discover
that a race has popped
up somewhere else.
Now, some people feel that--
so this is basically talking
about having a data race.
And a data race is
similar to the definition
of determinacy race,
but it says that you
have two logically
parallel instructions
and they don't hold
locks in common.
And then it's the
same definition.
If they access the same memory
location and one of them
performs a write,
then you have a--
then you have a data race bug.
But if they have
the locks in common,
if they both have acquired at
least one lock that's the same,
then you don't have a
data race, because that
means that you've now
successfully protected
the atomicity.
But it is still
nondeterministic and there
is a determinacy race,
just no data race.
And that's the big
distinction between data races
and determinacy races.
And on quiz 2, you better
know the difference
between data races
and determinacy races,
because they are different.
So a program may
have no determine--
may have no data races.
That doesn't mean
that it doesn't
have a determinacy race.
In fact, if it's got
any locks, it probably
has a determinacy race.
So one of the things is,
if I have no data races,
does that mean I have no bugs?
Suppose I have no
data races in my code.
Does that mean I have no bugs?
This is like an obvious answer
just by quizmanship, right?
So what might happen?
Think about it a little bit.
What might happen?
How could I have no data
races and yet there still
be a bug, even though--
I'm assuming it's a correct
piece of code otherwise.
In other words, when it
runs serially or whatever,
it's correct.
How could I end up having a
code-- no data races but still
have a bug?
AUDIENCE: It's still
nondeterministic [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes, but that
doesn't mean it's bad, right?
AUDIENCE: Well, you said that
it runs correctly serially.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the order that
things are put in or generated
might still be--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Might
still be different, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK.
Yes.
Let me give you an example
which is more to the point.
Here is a way of
making sure that I
have no data race, which is I
lock before I follow the table
slot value.
Then I unlock, and I lock
again and then I set the value.
So I haven't prevented
the atomicity.
Right now I've got an
atomicity violation,
but I have no data
races, because I never
have two things--
any two things that
are going to access
things at the same time
is protected by the lock.
But it didn't solve my
atomicity, so there's a--
you can definitely
have no data races,
but that doesn't mean
you have no bugs.
But, usually, what happens
is, if you have no data races,
then usually the programmer
actually got this code right.
It's one of these things where
demonstrating no data races
is in fact a very positive
thing in your code.
It doesn't mean the
programmer did right.
But most of the time, the reason
they're putting in the locks
is to provide atomicity
for something,
and they usually get it right.
They don't always get it right.
In fact, Java, for example,
had a very famous bug
early on in the way
that it specified
locking such that the--
you could look at the length
of a string and then modify it,
and then you would
end up with a race bug
because somebody else
could swoop in in between.
So they thought they were
providing atomicity and they
didn't.
So there's another
set of issues here
having to do with benign races.
Now, there's some people who
argue that no races are--
no determinacy races are benign.
And they make
academic statements
that I find quite
compelling, actually,
what they say, about races
and whether races are benign.
But, nevertheless,
the literature
also continues to use
the term benign race
for this kind of example.
So suppose we want to identify
what is the set of digits
that occurred in some array.
So here's an array with
a bunch of values in it,
each one being a
digit from 0 to 9.
So I could write a
little piece of code
that runs through a
digits array of length 10
and sets the number of digits
I've seen so far of each value
to be 0.
And now I go through--
and I'm going to do
this in parallel--
and I'm going to set, every
time I see a value A of i--
suppose A of i is 3--
I set the location
of A3 to be 1.
And, otherwise, and
now-- otherwise,
it's 0 because that's
what I had it before.
So here's the kind
of thing I have.
So, for example, I can
have both of those 6's--
or in parallel, we're going
to access the location
6 to set it to 1.
But they're both
setting it to 1.
It doesn't really matter
what order they do it in.
You're going to get the
same value there, 1.
And so there's a race.
Maybe we don't too much
care about that race,
because they're both
setting the same value.
We're not going to get
an incorrect value.
Well, not exactly.
We might get it on
some architecture.
On the Intel architectures, you
won't get an incorrect value,
on x86.
But there are codes
where the elements--
the array values are
not set atomically.
So, for example, on
the MIPS architecture,
in order to set a bite
to be a particular value,
you have to fetch the word,
mask out, set the word,
and then store it back in.
Set the byte and then store
it back into the word.
And so if there are two
guys who are basically
operating on that
same word location,
they will have a race,
even though in the code
it looks like they're
just setting bytes.
Does that make sense?
So nasty.
Nasty bugs.
That's why you should never do
nondeterministic programming
unless you have to.
So Cilksan allows you to
turn off race detection
for intentional races.
So if you really meant there
to be a race, as in this case,
you can turn it off.
This is dangerous but
practical, it turns out.
Usually you're
not turning it off
for-- because here's
what can happen.
You can turn it off and yet--
then there's something else
which is using that same stuff,
and now you're running Cilksan
without having turned it off
for exactly what
your race might be.
There are better solutions.
So in Intel's Cilk
Screen, there's
the notion of fake locks.
We just have not yet implemented
it in the open Cilk compiler
and in Cilksan.
We'll eventually
get to doing that.
And then people who take
this class in the future
will have an easier time
with that, because we'll be
able to check for that as well.
So any questions
about these notions?
So you can see the notions
of races can get quite hairy
and make it quite difficult
to do your debugging,
and in fact even can
confound your tools that
are supposed to be helping
you to get correct code.
All in the name of performance.
But we like performance.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I don't
really understand
how some architectures can cause
some error in race conditions.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
So how can some architectures
cause some error?
So here's the
thing, is that if I
have a, let's say,
a byte array, it
may be that this is stored
as a set of let's say
four-byte words.
And so although you
may write that A of 0
gets 1, what it does is it says,
let me fetch these four values,
because there is no
byte set instruction
on some architectures.
It can only set, in
this case, 32-bit words.
So it fetches the values.
It then-- into a register.
It then sets the value in
the register by masking.
So it doesn't set the
other things here.
And then it stores it back
so that it has a 1 here.
But what if somebody,
at the same time,
is storing into this location?
They will fetch it into
their own register,
set their byte,
mask it, et cetera.
And now my writeback
is going to--
we're going to have a lost
update in the writebacks.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK.
Good.
Very good question.
Yes, I know.
I went through that orally
a little bit quicker
than maybe I should have.
Great.
So let's talk a little
bit about implementation.
I always like to take
things down one level
below what you necessarily need
to know in order to do things.
But it's helpful to sort
of see how these things are
implemented, because then
that gives you a better
sense at a higher level
what your capabilities are
and how things are actually
working underneath.
So let's talk about mutexes.
So here, first of
all, understand there
are lots of different mutexes.
If you look at an
operating system,
they may have a half a dozen
or more different mutexes,
different locks that can
provide mutual exclusion,
or parameters that can be
set for what kind of mutexes.
So the first basic
difference in most things
is whether the mutex is
yielding or spinning.
So a yielding mutex returns
control to the operating system
when it blocks.
When a program tries to get--
when it tries to
get access, when
a thread tries to get access to
a given lock, if it is blocked,
it doesn't just sit
there and keep--
and spinning, where you're
basically-- spinning
means I just sit there checking
it and checking it and checking
it and checking it.
Instead what it does
is it says, oh, I'm
doing useless work here.
Let me go and return control
to the operating system.
Maybe there's another thread
that can run at the same time,
and therefore I'll give--
by switching myself out, by
yielding my scheduling quantum,
I will get better
efficiency overall,
because somebody--
some other thread that
is capable of running
can run at that point.
So is that a clear distinction
between spinning and yielding?
Another one is whether the mutex
is reentrant or nonreentrant.
A reentrant mutex
allows a thread
that is already holding a
lock to acquire it again.
A nonreentrant one
deadlocks if the thread
attempts to require a
mutex it already holds.
So I grab a lock, and now
I go to a piece of code
that says grab that lock.
So very simple.
I can check to see
whether I have--
if I want to be
reentrant, I can check,
do I have that lock already?
And if I do, then I don't
actually have to acquire it.
I just keep going.
But that's extra overhead.
It's faster for me to
have a nonreentrant lock,
where I just simply
grab the lock,
and if somebody has
got it, including me,
then it's a deadlock.
But now if there's
the possibility
that I could reacquire a lock,
then that might not be safe.
You have to worry
about-- the program has
to worry about that now.
Is that clear, that one?
And then a final basic
property of mutexes
is whether they're
fair or unfair.
So here's the thing.
It's the easiest to think about
it in the context of spinning.
I have several
threads that basically
came to the same lock, and we
decided they're going to spin.
They're just going to sit there
continually checking, waiting
for that lock to be free.
So when finally the guy
who has it unlocks it,
maybe I've got a half a
dozen threads sitting there.
One of them wins.
And which one wins?
Well, they're spinning.
It could be any one of them.
Then it has one.
And so the issue
that can go on is
you could have what's called
a starvation problem, where
some guy is sitting there for
a really long time waiting
while everybody else is
continually grabbing locks
out from under his or her nose.
So with a fair mutex,
basically what you do
is you go for the one that's
been waiting the longest,
essentially.
And so, therefore,
you never have
to wait more than for however
many things were there
when you got there
before you're able to go.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Why is that better?
CHARLES LEISERSON: It can be
better because you may freeze
out our service if there's
something that's-- you may
never get to do the
thing that you want to do
because there's something
else always interfering with
the ability for that part of
the program to make progress.
This tends to be
more of an issue
in concurrent
programming, where you
have different programs
that are trying
to accomplish
different tasks and you
want to accomplish both tasks.
It does not come across--
in parallel programming,
mostly we deal with unfair--
often unfair spinning locks
because they're the cheapest.
And we just trust
that, a, we're not
going to have any critical
regions-- we write
our code so we don't have
critical regions that
are really long, so nobody ever
has to wait a very long time.
But, indeed, dealing
with a contention issue,
as we talked about last
week, can make a difference.
good.
So here's an implementation
of a simple spinning mutex
an assembly language.
So the first thing
it does is it checks
to see if the-- the mutex
is free if its value is 0.
So it compares the
value of the mutex to 0.
And if it is 0, it
says, oh, it's free.
Let me go get it.
It then-- to get the mutex,
what it does is it moves a 1
into the--
it basically moves
1 into a register,
and then it exchanges the
mutex with that register eax.
And then it compares
to see whether or not
it actually got the mutex.
And if it didn't, then it
goes back up to the top
and starts again.
And then the other branch
is at the top there.
It does this pause,
and this apparently
is due to a bug in
x86 that they end up
having to put this pause
instruction in there.
And then, otherwise,
you jump to where
the Spin_Mutex is and go again.
And then, once you've
done the Critical_Section,
when you're done you free
it by just setting it to 0.
So the question here is--
so the exchange instruction
is an atomic exchange.
So it takes the register and the
memory value and it swaps them,
and you can't have
anything come in.
So one of the things
that might have you
confused a little bit
here is, wait a second.
I checked to see if
the mutex is free,
and then I tried to get it
to test if I was successful.
Why?
Why can't I just start out by
essentially going to get mutex?
I mean, why do I need any of
the code between Spin_Mutex
and Get_Mutex?
So if I just started with
Get_Mutex, I would move a 1 in.
I would exchange, check
to see if I could get it.
If I had it, fine.
Then I execute the end.
If not, I would go
back and try again.
So why-- because if
somebody has it, by the way,
the value that I'm going
to get is going to be 1.
And that's what I swapped in,
so I haven't changed anything.
I go back and I check again.
So why do I need
that first part?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's faster
to just get [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
Maybe it's faster.
So, indeed, it's
because it's faster.
Even though you're executing
extra code, it's faster.
Tell me why it's faster.
And this will take
you-- you have
to think a little bit
about the cache protocols
and the invalidation issue.
So why is it going to be faster?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because I do
the atomic exchange.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK, good.
Say more.
AUDIENCE: Basically, just
to exchange atomically,
you have to have [INAUDIBLE].
And you bring it in
only just to do a swap.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
So it turns out the exchange
operation is like a write.
And so in order to
do a write, what do I
need to do for the
cache line that it's on?
AUDIENCE: To bring it in.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
To bring it in.
But how does it have
to be brought in?
Remember, the cache lines have--
let's ima--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: You have to
invalidate on the other ones,
and you have to hold
it in what state?
Remember, the cache lines have--
if we take a look at just a
simplified protocol where--
the MSI's protocol.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
You have to have it--
in MSI or MESI, you have
to bring it in in modified
or at least exclusive state.
So exclusive is for
the MESI protocol.
We mentioned that but
we didn't really do it.
Mostly we just went--
but I have to bring
it in and modify it,
where I guarantee there
are no other copies.
So if I've got two guys that
are polling on this location,
they're both continually
invalidating each other,
and you create a whole bunch of
traffic on the memory network.
That's going to slow
everything down.
Whereas if I do the first one,
what state do I get it in?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: Then
you get it in shared state.
What does the other
guy get it in?
AUDIENCE: Shared.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Shared state.
And now I keep
going, just having
it spinning in my
own local cache,
not generating any local
traffic until the--
until somebody releases
the lock, in which case
it invalidates all those.
And now you can actually
get a little bit of a storm
after the fact.
There are in fact locks
where you don't even
get a storm after the
fact called MCS locks.
But this kind of lock is,
for most practical purposes,
just fine.
So everybody follow
that description
of what's going on there?
So that first code, for
correctness purpose,
is not important.
For performance,
it is important.
Isn't it great that you guys
can read assembly language?
Now suppose that-- this
is a spinning mutex.
Suppose that I want to
do a yielding mutex.
How does this code
have to change?
So this is a spinning one.
It just keeps checking.
Instead, I want
to return control
to the operating system.
So how does this code
change if I do that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Instead of
the pause, [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON: Like that.
Yes, exactly.
So instead of doing that
pause instruction, which--
the documentation on
this is not very clear.
I'd love to have the inside
scoop on why they really
had to do the pause there.
But in any case,
you take that no op
that they want to have in
there and you replace it
with just a call to the yield,
which allows the operating
system to schedule
something else.
And then when it's
your turn again,
it resumes from that point.
So that's the yield.
So that's the difference
in implementation,
essentially, between a spinning
mutex and a yielding mutex.
Now, there's another
kind of mutex
that is kind of cool which is
called a competitive mutex.
So think about it this way.
I have competing goals.
One is I want to get the
mutex as quickly as possible
after it's released.
I don't want-- if
it's unlocked, I
don't want to sit there
for a really long time
before I actually acquire it.
And, two, yes, but I don't
want to sit there spinning
for a really long time.
And then-- because as
long as I'm doing that,
I'm taking up cycles and
not accomplishing anything.
Let me turn it over to some
other thread that can use
the cycles more effectively.
So there are those two goals.
How can I get the best
of both worlds here?
Something that's close to
the best of both worlds.
It's not absolutely the
best of both worlds,
but it's close to the
best of both worlds.
What strategy could I do?
So I want to claim it very soon.
So the point is that
the spinning mutex
achieves goal 1, and the
yielding mutex achieved goal 2.
So how can I-- what can
I do to get both goals?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
could use some sort of message
passing to [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON:
So you're saying
use message passing to inform--
AUDIENCE: The waiting threads.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
--the waiting threads.
I'm think of something a
lot simpler in this context.
Because the message
passing, you're
going to have to go through--
to do message passing
properly, you actually
need to use mutexes that
are to implement it.
So you want to be a little
bit careful about that.
But interesting idea.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
try using an interrupt?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Using an interrupt.
How would you do that?
AUDIENCE: Like once
the [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
So, typically, if you
implement interrupt
you also need to have some
mutual exclusions to do it
properly, but--
I mean, hardware
will support that.
That's pretty
heavy-handed as well.
There's actually a
very simple solution.
I'm seeing familiar hands.
I want to see some
unfamiliar hands.
Who's got an unfamiliar hand?
I see.
You raised your
left hand that time
instead of your right hand.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You try
to have whichever
one is closest to being back
to the beginning of the cycle
take the lock.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Hard
to measure that, right?
How would you write
code to measure that?
Yes.
Hmm.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question, actually.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK, good.
AUDIENCE: Why does
it [INAUDIBLE]??
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Why doesn't it have a?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Why does yielding
mutex [INAUDIBLE]??
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Because if I yield--
so what's the-- how often does--
if I context switch, how often
is it going to be that I--
how long am I going to
have to wait, typically,
before I am scheduled again?
When a code yields to
the operating system,
how often does the
operating system normally
do context switching?
What's the rate at which
it context switches
for the different
multiplexing of threads
that it does onto the
available processors?
What's the rate at
which it shifts?
Oh, this is--
OK, that's going
to be on the quiz.
This is a numeracy thing.
Yes.
Do you know how frequently?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sub-millisecond [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Not quite, but you're
not off by more than
an order of magnitude.
So what are the typical
rates that the system
does context switching?
So in human time, it's
the blink of an eye.
So it's actually
around 10 milliseconds.
So it does a hundred
times a second.
Some of them do.
Some do 60 times a second.
That's how often it switches.
Now, let's say it's a
hundred times a second, 10
milliseconds.
So you're pretty close.
10 milliseconds.
How many orders of magnitude
is that from the execution
of a simple instruction?
So we're going at
more than a gigahertz.
And so a gigahertz
is 10 to the ninth,
and we're talking
10 to the minus 9,
10 to the minus 2.
So that's 10 million
instruction opportunities
that we miss if we switch out.
And, of course, we'd probably
only switch out for half our--
where are you along the thing.
So you're only switching
out maybe for half,
assuming nothing else
is going on there.
But that means you're not
grabbing the lock quickly
after it's released,
because you've
got 10 million instructions
that are going to execute
before you're going to have a
chance to come back in and grab
it.
So that's why a yielding one
does not grab it quickly.
Whereas spinning is like
we're executing this stuff
at the rate of gigahertz,
checking again, checking again,
checking again.
So why-- so what's
the strategy here?
What can I do?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Maybe we could
spin for a little bit
and then yield.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Hey, what a good idea.
Spin for a while and then yield.
So the idea being, hey, if
the lock is released soon,
then I will be able
to grab it immediately
because I'm spinning.
If it takes a long time
for the lock to yield,
well, I will yield eventually.
So yes, but how long to spin?
How long shall I spin?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Somewhere close
to the amount of time
it takes to yield and come back.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
Basically as long as a
context switch takes, as long
as it takes to go
out and come back.
And if you do that,
then you never
wait more than twice
the optimal time.
This is competitive analysis,
which the theoreticians have
gone off-- there's brilliant
work in competitive analysis.
So the idea here is
that if the mutex is
released while you're spinning,
then this strategy is optimal.
Because you just
sat there spinning,
and as soon as it was there
you got it on the next cycle.
If the mutex is released
after the yield,
you've already spun
for the equal to that.
So you'll come back and get it
within at most a factor of 2.
This is-- by the
way, this shows up
in the theory literature,
if you're interested,
is it's called the
ski rental problem.
And here's the idea.
You're going to go--
your friends have persuaded
you to go try skiing.
Snow skiing, right?
Pu-chu, pu-chu, pu-chu.
Right?
And so you say, gee,
should I buy the equipment
or should I rent?
After all, you may discover
that you rent and then--
you buy it, and then
you break your leg
and never want to go back.
Well, then, if you've bought
it's been very expensive.
And if you've rented, well,
then you're probably better off.
On the other hand, if it
turns out you like it,
you're now accumulating
the costs going forward.
And so the question is,
well, what's your strategy?
And the idea is, well, let's
look at what renting costs
and what buying costs.
Let me rent until it's
equal to the cost of buying
and then buy.
And then I'm within
a factor of 2
of having spent the optimal
amount of money for--
because then if I break my leg
after that, well, at least I--
I got-- I didn't spend
more than a factor of 2.
And if I get it before,
then I've spent optimally.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when you say how
long a context switch takes,
is that in milliseconds or--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
10 milliseconds.
Yes.
So spin for 10 milliseconds,
and then switch.
So now the point is that
when you come back in,
the other job's going to run
for 10 milliseconds or whatever.
So if you get switched out,
then if the lock is released,
you're going to be done
in 20 milliseconds.
And so you'll be
within a factor of 2.
And if it happened if the
lockout released before then,
you're right there to grab it.
Now, it turns out that
there's a really clever
randomized algorithm--
I love this algorithm--
from 1994 that achieves
a competitive ratio
of e over e minus 1 using
a randomized strategy.
And I'll encourage
you, those of you
have a theoretical bent,
to go take a look at that.
It's very clever.
So, basically, you have
some probability of,
at every step, of whether
you, at that point,
decide to yield or
continue spinning.
And by using a
randomized strategy,
you can actually get
this to e over e minus 1.
Questions about this?
So this is sort of
some of the basics.
I'm glad we went
over some of that,
because everybody should know
these basic numbers about what
things cost.
Because, otherwise, you
don't know where to spend it.
So context switching time is on
the order of 10 milliseconds.
How long is a disk
access compared to--
yes.
What's a disk access?
AUDIENCE: 150 cycles?
CHARLES LEISERSON: 150 cycles?
Hmm, that's a--
AUDIENCE: Or is that the cache?
CHARLES LEISERSON: That
would be accessing DRAM.
Accessing DRAM, if it wasn't
in cache, might be 150 cycles.
So two orders of
magnitude or so.
So what about a disk access?
How long does that take?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Milliseconds?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
Several milliseconds.
So 10 milliseconds or 5
milliseconds depending
upon how fast your disk is.
But, once again, it's on
the order of milliseconds.
So it's helpful to know
some of these numbers,
because, otherwise, where
are you spending your time?
Especially, we're sort of
doing performance engineering
in the small, basically
looking within the pro--
within a multicore processor.
Most performance engineering
is on all the stuff
on the outside, dealing with
networking, and file systems,
and stuff where things
are really costly,
and where, if you actually
have a lot of time,
you can write a fast piece
of code that can figure out
how you should best deal
with these slow parts
of your system.
So those are all sort
of good numbers to know.
You'll probably see
some of them on quiz 2.
Deadlock.
I mentioned deadlock earlier.
Let's talk about what deadlock
is and understand this.
Once again, I expect some
of you have seen this,
but I still want to go
through it because it's
hugely important material.
And this is the issue, that
holding more than one lock
at a time can be dangerous.
So imagine that thread 1 says,
I'm going to lock A, lock B,
execute the critical section,
unlock B, unlock A, were A
and B are mutexes.
And thread 2 does
something very similar.
It locks B and locks A. Then
it does the critical section,
then it unlocks A
and then unlocks
B. So what can happen here?
So thread 1 locks
A, thread 2 locks
B. Thread 1 can't go and lock
B because thread 2 has it.
Thread 2 can't go and lock
A because thread 1 has it.
So they sit there, blocked.
I don't care if they're
spinning or yielding.
They're not going anywhere.
So this is the ultimate
loss of performance.
It's like-- it's incorrect.
It's like you're stuck,
you've deadlocked.
Now, there's three basic
conditions for deadlock.
Everybody understands
this, right?
Is there anybody who has
a question, because just--
OK.
There's three conditions
you need for deadlock.
The first one is
mutual exclusion,
that you're going to
have exclusive control
over the resources.
The second is nonpreemption.
You don't release
your resources.
You hold until you
finish using them.
And three is circular waiting.
You have a cycle of threads,
in which each thread is
blocked waiting for resources
held by the next one.
In this case, the
resource is the lock.
And so if you remove any
one of these constraints,
you can come up with
solutions that won't deadlock.
So, for example, it
could be that when
I try to acquire a lock,
if somebody else has them,
I take it away.
That could be one thing.
Now, they may get into other
issues, which is like, well,
but what if he's actually
doing real work or whatever?
So all of these
things have things.
Or I don't insist that it be
mutual exclusion, except that's
the kind of problem that
we're trying to solve.
So these are generally
the three things
that are necessary in order
to have a deadlock situation.
Now, in any discussion
of deadlock,
you have to talk about
dining philosophers.
When I was an undergraduate--
and I graduated in 1975 from
Yale, a humanities school--
I was taught the
dining philosophers,
because, after all,
philosophy is what
you find at humanities schools.
I mean, we have a
philosophy department too.
Don't get me wrong.
But at Yale the
humanities is huge.
And so philosophy,
I guess they thought
this would appeal to
the people who were not
real techies in the background.
I sort of like--
I was a techie in the midst of
all these non-technical people.
Dining philosophers
is a story of deadlock
told by Tony Hoare based
on an examination question
by Edsger Dijkstra.
And it's been embellished
over the years
by many, many, many retellers.
And I like the Chinese
version of this.
There's versions where they
use forks, but I'm going to--
this is going to
be-- they're dining--
I'm going to say that they are
eating noodles with chopsticks.
And there are n philosophers
seated around the table,
and between every plate of
noodles there's a chopstick.
And so in order
to eat the noodles
they need two chopsticks, which
to me sounds very natural.
And so here's the code
for philosopher i.
So he's a philosopher, so he
starts by thinking for a while.
And then he gets hungry,
he or she gets hungry.
So the philosopher grabs
the chopstick on the right--
on the left, sorry.
And then he grabs the one on
the right, which is i plus 1.
But he has to do that mod n,
because if it's the last one,
you've got to go around
and grab the first one.
Then eats, and then it
unlocks the two chopsticks.
And now they can be used by
the other dining philosophers
because they don't think much
about sanitation and so forth.
Because they're too
busy thinking, right?
But what happens?
What's wrong with this solution?
What happens?
What can happen for this?
It's very simple.
I need two chopsticks.
I grab one, I grab
the other, I eat.
One day, what happens?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Everyone grabs
the chopstick to the left
and they're all stuck
with one chopstick.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
They grab one to the left,
and now they go to the right.
It's not there, and they starve.
One day they grab
all the things,
so we have the starving
philosophers problem.
So motivated by this
problem-- yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Is there any way
to temporarily unlock it?
Like the philosopher could just
hand the chopstick [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
So if you're willing to preempt,
then that would be preemption.
As I say, it's got to be
nonpreemptive in order
for deadlock to occur.
In this case, yes.
But you also have to
worry in those cases.
Could be, oh, well if
I couldn't get both,
let me put them both down.
But then you can have a
thing that's called livelock.
So they all pick up their left.
They see the right one's
busy, so they put it down
so somebody else can have it.
They look around.
Oh, OK.
Let me pick up one.
Oh, no.
OK.
And so they still starve even
though they've done that.
So in that kind of situation,
you could put in a time delay.
You could say-- let everybody
pick a random number to have
a randomized scheme
so that we're not--
so there are other
solutions if you
don't insist on nonpreemption.
I'm going to give you one
where we have nonpreemption
but we still avoid
deadlock, and it's
to go for that cyclic problem.
So here's the idea.
Suppose that we can
linearly order the mutexes.
So I pick some order
of the mutexes,
so that whenever a thread
holds a mutex L sub i
and attempts to lock
another mutex L sub j,
we have that in
this linear order--
L sub i comes before L sub j.
Then you can't have a deadlock.
So in this case, for
the dining philosophers,
it would, for example, number
the chopsticks from 1 to n,
or 0 to n minus 1, whatever.
And then grab the smaller one
and then grab the larger one.
And then it says then you
would never have a deadlock.
And so here's the proof.
You know I like proofs.
Proofs are really important.
So I'm going to show you that
if you do that, you couldn't
have a cycle of waiting.
So suppose you had
a cycle of waiting.
We're in a situation
where everybody
is holding chopsticks,
and one of them
is waiting for another
one, which is waiting for--
all the way around
to the first one.
That's what we need
for deadlock to occur.
So let me just look at what's
the largest mutex on the cycle.
Let's call that L max.
And suppose that it's waiting on
mutex L held by the next thread
in the cycle.
Well, then, we have
something that's
bigger than the maximum one.
And so that contradicts the
fact that I grab them-- whenever
I grab them, I do it in order.
So very simple-- very simple
proof that you can't have
deadlock if you grab them
according to a linear order.
And so for this
particular problem,
what I do is,
instead of grabbing
the one on the left and
one the right, as I say,
you grab the smaller of
the two and then grab
the larger of the two.
And then you're guaranteed
to have no deadlock.
Does that make sense?
Now, if you're going
to use locks in Cilk,
you have to realize
that in the operating--
in the runtime system
of Cilk, they're doing--
they're using locks.
You can't see them.
They're encapsulated,
as we talked about.
The nondeterminism in
Cilk is encapsulated.
It's still going on
underneath the covers.
And if you start introducing
your own nondeterminism
through the use of locks
you can run into trouble
if you're not careful.
And let me give you an example.
This is a situation-- you can
deadlock your program in Cilk
with just one lock.
So here's an example of
a code that does that.
So main spawns off foo.
And foo basically locks the
lock L and then unlocks it.
And, meanwhile, after
it spawns off foo,
the continuation goes
and it locks L itself,
and then does a sync,
and then it unlocks it.
So what happens here?
We sort of have a
situation like this,
where the locking I've
done with an open bracket,
and an unlock, a release, I'm
doing with a closed bracket.
So I'm spawning off foo,
which is the lower part there,
and locking and unlocking.
And up above unlocking
then unlocking.
So what can happen here?
I can go and I basically spawn
off the child, but then I lock.
And now the child goes and
it says, whoops, can't--
foo is going to wait here
because it can't grab the lock
because it's owned by main.
And now we get to
the point where
main has to wait for
the sync, and the child
is never going to
complete because I
hold the resource that the
child needs to complete.
So don't hold mutexes
across Cilk syncs.
That's the lesson there.
There are actually
places you can,
but if you don't hold
them across that,
then you won't run into
this particular problem.
A good strategy is only
holding mutexes within strands.
So there's no parallelism.
So you have it bounded.
And also, that's a
good idea generally
because you want to hold
mutexes as short amount of time
as you possibly can.
So, for example, if you
have a big calculation
and then you want to assign
something atomically,
don't put the big calculation
inside the critical region.
Move the calculation
outside the critical region,
do the calculation
you need to do,
and then acquire the locks
just to do the interaction
you need to set a value.
And then you'll have
a lot faster code
because you're not holding up
other threads for a long time.
And always try to avoid
nondeterministic programming.
But that's not always possible.
So any questions about that?
Then I want to go on a
really interesting topic
because it's a really
recent research level topic,
and that's to talk about
transactional memory.
Who's heard this term before?
Anybody?
So the idea is to have
database transactions,
that you have things like
database transactions
where the atomicity is
happening implicitly.
You don't specify locks.
You just say this is
a critical region.
Don't interrupt me while
I do this critical region.
The system works everything out.
Here's a good example of
where it might be useful.
Suppose we want to do a
concurrent graph computation.
And so you take people
involved in parallel
and distributed computing
at MIT and you say,
OK, I want to do Gaussian
elimination on this graph.
Now, you guys, I'm
sure most of you
know Gaussian elimination
from the matrix context.
Do you know what it
means in a graph context?
So if you have a sparse matrix,
you actually have a graph.
And Gaussian elimination is a
way of manipulating the graph,
and you get exactly
the same behavior
as you get in the dense one.
So I'll show you what it is.
You basically pick
somebody to eliminate.
[STUDENTS LAUGH]
And now what you do is look at
all this vertex's neighbors.
Those guys.
And what you do is you
eliminate that vertex--
bye bye-- and you
interconnect all the neighbors
with all the edges that
don't already exist.
And that's Gaussian elimination.
And if you think of it in
terms of matrix fashion,
the question is, if you
have a sparse matrix,
where are you going
to get fill in?
What are the places
that you need
to update when you do
a pivot in Gaussian
elimination in a matrix?
So that's the basic
notion of graph--
of doing Gaussian elimination.
But now we want to deal
with the concurrency.
And the problem occurs
if I want to eliminate
two nodes at the same time.
Because now they're
adjacent to each other,
and if I just do
what I expressed,
there's going to be all kinds
of atomicity violations,
et cetera.
By the way, the reason I'm
picking these two folks
is because they're
going to a better place.
So how do you deal with this?
And so in transactional memory,
what I want to be able to do
is just simply say,
OK, here's the thing
that I need to be atomic.
And so if I look
at this code, it's
basically saying who
are my neighbors,
and then let me identify
all of the edges that
need to be removed, the
ones that I just showed you
that we removed.
Now let me get rid
of the element v.
And now, for all of
the neighbors of u,
let us add in the edge
between the neighbor and--
between the pairs of neighbors.
So that's basically
what it's doing.
And I'd like to just
say that's atomic.
And so the idea is
that if I express
that as a transaction,
then the idea
is that, on the
transaction commit,
all the memory updates
in the critical region
appear to take it
happen at once.
However, in
transaction, remember
the idea is, rather than
forcing it to go forward,
I can have the
transactions abort.
So if I get a conflict, I'll
abort one and restart it.
And then the
restarted transaction
may take a different code
path, because, after all, I
may have restructured
the graph underneath.
And so it may do something
different the second time
through than the first.
It may also abort
again and so forth.
So when you study transaction,
transactional memory--
let me just do a
couple of definitions.
One is a conflict.
That's when you have two
transactions that are--
they can't both complete.
One of them has to be aborted.
And aborting, by the
way, is once again
violating the
nonpreemptive nature.
Here we're going to
preempt one of them
by keeping all the states
so I can roll a state back
and restart it from scratch.
So contention
resolution is deciding
which of the two
conflicting transactions
to wait or to abort and restart,
and under what conditions
you do that.
So the resolution
manager has to figure out
what happens in the
case of contention.
And then forward progress is
avoiding deadlock of course,
but also livelock
and starvation.
You want to make sure that
you're going to make--
because what you don't
want to have happen,
for example, is that
two transactions
keep aborting each other and
you never make forward progress.
And throughput, well, you'd
like to run as many transactions
as concurrently as possible.
So I'm going to show you an
algorithm for doing this.
It's a really simple algorithm.
It happens to be one
that I discovered
just a couple of years ago.
And I was surprised that it did
not appear in the literature,
and so I wrote a very
short paper on it.
Because what happens for
a lot of people is they--
if they discover there's
a lot of aborting,
they say, oh, well let's
grab a global lock.
And then if everybody
grabs a global lock,
you can do this sort of thing.
You can't deadlock
with a single lock
if you're not also doing things
like Cilk sync or whatever.
But, in any case, if you
have just a single lock,
everybody falls back
to the single lock,
and then you have no
concurrency in your program,
no performance,
until everybody gets
through the difficult time.
So this is an algorithm that
doesn't require a global lock.
So it assumes the
transactional memory system
will log the reads and writes.
That's typically true of
any transaction, where
you log what reads
and writes you're
doing so that you can
either abort and roll back,
or you can--
when you abort-- or else
you sandbox things and then
atomically commit them.
And so we have
all the mechanisms
for aborting and rolling back.
These are all very interesting
in their own right,
and restarting.
And this is going to basically
use a lock-based approach that
uses two ideas.
One is the notion of what's
called a finite ownership
array, and another is a thing
called release-sort-reacquire.
And let me explain
those two things,
and I'll show you really quickly
how this beautiful algorithm
works.
So you have an array of
anti-starvation mutual
exclusion locks.
So these are ones that are
going to be fair, so that you're
always going to the oldest one.
And you can do an
acquire, but we're also
going to add in a try acquire.
Tell me whether, if I tried
to acquire, I would get it.
That is, if I get
it, give it to me.
If I don't get it, don't wait.
Just tell me that I didn't
get it, and then release.
And there's an owner function
that maps all of the--
function h that maps my
universe of memory locations
to the indexes in
this finite ownership
array, this lock array.
So the lock has length--
array has length n,
has n slots in it.
To lock a location x in the
set of all possible memory
locations, you actually
acquire lock of h of x.
So you can think of
h as a hash function,
but it doesn't have to be a
fair hash function or whatever.
Any function will do.
And then, yes, there will be
some advantages to picking
some functions or another one.
So rather than actually
locking the location
or locking the object,
I lock a location
that essentially I hash
to from that object.
So if two guys are trying
to grab the same location,
they will both
grab the same lock
because they've got
the same hash function.
But I may have
inadvertent locks where
if I were locking the
objects themselves,
I wouldn't have them both
trying to acquire the same lock.
That might happen
in this algorithm.
So here's the idea.
The first idea is called
release, sort, and reacquire.
So that's the ownership array
part that I just explained.
Now here's the release,
sort, reacquire.
Before you access a
memory location x,
simply try to grab
lock of x greedily.
And if you have a conflict--
so if you don't have a
conflict, you get it.
You just simply try to get it.
And if you can, that's great.
If not, then what I'm going to
do is roll back the transaction
but don't release
the locks I hold,
and then release all
the locks with indexes
greater than h of x.
And then I'm going to
acquire the lock that I want.
And now, at that point, I've
released all the bigger locks,
so I'm acquiring the next lock.
And then I reacquire the
released locks in sorted order.
So I go through all the locks
I released and I reacquire them
in sorted order.
And then I start my
transaction over again.
I try again.
So what happens each time
through this process,
I'm always--
whenever I'm trying
to acquire a lock,
I'm only holding locks
that are smaller.
But each time that I
restart, I have one more lock
that I didn't used to
have before I restart
my transaction, which I've
acquired in the order,
in the linear order, in
that ownership array from 0
to n minus 1.
And so here's the algorithm.
I'll let you guys look
at it in more detail,
because I see our time is up.
And it's actually fun
to take a look at,
and we'll put the paper online.
There's one other topic that
I wanted to go through here
which you should know about,
is this locking anomaly
called convoying.
And this was actually a bug
that we had-- a performance bug
that we had in our
original and MIT-Cilk.
So it's kind of a neat one to
see and how we resolved it.
And that's it.